through my role as a social media
princess I can share a good news stories
via Facebook such as the new homes bonus
scheme where Tory to invest money into
delivering community
I love torch the woodlands you know
everybody so friendly I love walking
going for hiking and you can't beat the
coastline along here between west at
home and heart and it's absolutely
stunning part of the rural area there's
still plenty to do you know a fun day
out with the family shopping going to
the cinema or visiting one of the many
attractions here my favorite toys
benefit is gonna be the best time
flexitime is great here at origins it
allows me to get more both from the
hobbies that I really enjoyed
particularly on which is live-action
role play where we dress up in medieval
garb and fight each other in fictional
batteries
flexitime allows me to enjoy my hobby
which is cremated on a boat bike more
flexitime I build up more time I can be
on my bike great benefits of those scope
to advanced or career so if you're a
loader and you either there's always the
opportunity to do that it's up to you to
be motivated to go for it and better
yourself and I've done that recently by
doing the noble fire management course
since I've worked for torij he's the
best job of in red
[Music]